thunderstorm spring wind rain loud
rumbles and flashes of lightning but
researchers have known since the 1980s
that they can also bring on asthma
attacks in one extreme case during a
2016 thunderstorm in Australia thousands
of people experienced asthma attacks and
at least nine people died thunderstorm
asthma events have been reported in
Australia Europe North America and the
Middle East but researchers are only now
coming to understand how one leads to
the other and how to set up warning
systems it's thought that pollen is the
likely trigger for thunderstorm asthma
but pollen grains are too large to be
directly inhaled into lung tissue to
cause an asthma attack a thunderstorm
can change that though by sweeping up
pollen grains kilometers into the sky
there the grains encounter high humidity
that scientists believe causes the large
grains to swell and rupture into
hundreds of smaller pieces writing down
drafts in the storm the pollen shrapnel
comes crashing back to earth and its
small enough to enter the lower
respiratory tract and cause an
inflammatory response like an asthma
attack in Melbourne Australia
thunderstorm asthma has been reported
seven times since 1984 the city appears
to have all the right conditions for an
epidemic of this sort nearby fields of
pollen producing rye grass regular
thunderstorms and a large population
analyzing hospital and meteorological
records researchers found that all of
the thunderstorm asthma cases occurred
in the month of November which coincided
with when pollen levels were high also
the thunderstorms typically included
multiple storm cells which may have
helped spread pollen shrapnel Victoria
state of which Melbourne is the capital
last year rolled out one of the world's
first thunderstorm asthma warning
systems it combines thunderstorm
predictions from weather agencies with
pollen counts from eight counting
stations across the state this gives
people time to plan for coming storms
currently the team is able to forecast
three days before a thunderstorm asthma
event occurs
you